okay uh welcome everybody uh I'm morce
Samuels the director of the Yale program
for the study of anti-Semitism and it's
my great pleasure to welcome you today
to uh this hybrid lecture both in person
and on Zoom it's our first uh attempt to
do a hybrid um format here so the way
it's going to work is that um I will
introduce Professor fineberg he's going
to speak for about 40 minutes uh and
then we'll take 20 minutes of questions
from the audience both in person and on
Zoom so those of you on Zoom we ask you
to submit your questions using the Q&A
function at the bottom of your screen
the chat function is disabled and then
we will ask in person professor fineberg
your questions um that you submit uh in
the Q&A function and you can submit
those questions at any time during uh
the lecture you don't have to wait until
the end so I will now introduce
Professor Feinberg um iel Feinberg is
one of the leading researchers doing
quantitative analysis of anti-Semitism
an extremely valuable contribution to
the field he is associate professor of
political science and anti-Semitism
study
and is the director of the center for
Holocaust studies and human rights at
Gratz College overseeing the largest
Holocaust and genocide graduate program
in the world his re his research has
been widely featured in leading
international journals and media outlets
and his scholarship is frequently
utilized by practitioners and policy
makers concerned with the insecurity of
marginalized groups and the perseverance
of the Jewish community in addition to
all of this um and in addition to his um
his academic position he's also a
quantitative research fellow at the
Anti-Defamation League Center for
anti-Semitism research and he recently
completed a three-year term as the
junior faculty chair at the academic
engagement Network his anti-semitic bias
incident analysis was inducted into the
Congressional Record during the 2019
house Judiciary committee's hearing on
hate crime and the rise of white
nationalism uh his talk today is
entitled clarifying anti-Semitism
through experiments exploring blam
responsibility and hate crime so please
join me in welcoming back to Yale iel
fbook uh thank you for that very very
kind introduction Professor s um very
excited to be back at Yale to be Pres
presenting some of the experimental
research that I'm doing along with my
colleague Dr Jacob Scott Lewis at
Washington State University uh a lot of
This research is pretty new for us and
we're really excited to begin to share
this research with the public so we
really welcome all of your questions
your comments and ways that we can
improve upon and build on This research
so the title as Dr Samuel said is
clarifying anti-Semitism through
experiments exploring uh blame respons
ility and hate
crime sorry everyone just getting the
clicker ready okay I think it's critical
to talk about why I'm engaged in this
process although I'm proud that my
research is objective as I'm able to
design it I am motivated by an
overarching normative concern about
violent anti-Semitism and I think that
these three images share a lot of
important elements that we need to be
thinking about when we're constructing
anti-Semitism research today I think
most people are familiar with this image
on the right of the Tree of Life
synagogue Memorial outside of the tree
of life after the most lethal
anti-semitic attack on American Jews in
our country's
history on the left is the Amia attack
in Buenos ARIS an attack that most
American Jews are far less familiar with
but resulted in 87 fatalities many
consider this attack to be the most
lethal anti-semitic attack post
Holocaust and what's really critical
here as we struggle with understanding
the role of anti-israel sentiment and
anti- Zionism and explaining
anti-Semitism is an image from the riots
that happened in SAR South France in
2014 where Jewish businesses and
indiscriminate Jewish individ or Jewish
individuals are indiscriminately
targeted because of the behavior of
Israel cler struggles continue sorry
everyone give me one
second okay success all right there is
concern surrounding Rising anti-Semitism
here in the United States there is a
general feeling that Jews are less safe
how do we know this what are the
empirics that we're utilizing to base
this information on well the acjc has
done a survey of the American Jewish
population where they
ask several questions that help us to
determine the security of Jewish
Americans one of the questions that they
frequently ask in the
survey do you think that anti-Semitism
is is a problem in the United States
from the most recent iteration of the
survey 89% of Americans say that
anti-Semitism is a problem in the United
States in fact this number covers
between about 80 and 95% in any given
year it doesn't tell us a great deal at
an individual level about Jewish
insecurity but what I think helps us to
articulate the current
situation quite greatly is that 82% of
American Jews believe that anti-semitism
has increased there is a feeling that
there is increasing anti-Semitism these
numbers are higher than many previous
years and that 41% of American Jews
report feeling less secure than a year
ago only 4% feel more secure again these
numbers seem to show that there is a new
feeling a new increased feeling of
insecurity amongst American Jews the
other thing that we often do is look to
these surveys where we asked about
anti-semitic Trope alignment so the ADL
has offered up many surveys since 1964
using the same question battery aimed at
measuring the number of anti-Semitic
Trope alignment that exists amongst the
American population what do we see a big
difference from 2019 to
2022 this shift this Gap when % of
Americans constitute about 54 million
Americans that now fall into the
category of those that align with at
least six of the 11 antiemetic tropes
that the ADL
measures okay so a little bit about what
I'm going to be doing today in this
presentation I want to do a little bit
of housekeeping first I never know
exactly who my audience is so I think
it's important to do a brief overview of
anti-Semitism and share a little bit
about anti-Semitism in pars I'm going to
talk to you and provide you an overview
of some of the experimental literature
that already examines
anti-Semitism and then I'm going to
share two of my own uh experiments that
I've done again with with Jacob Scott
Lewis at Washington State exploring
blame attribution and responsibility to
speak out as well as the effects of hate
crime exposure on foreign policy
preferences and then I'm going to tease
everybody with a little bit of future
survey so let's start with defining
antism a tremendous amount of time
resources and concern surround how do we
Define anti-Semitism it's one of these
enduring
questions on the
left is the IRA definition of
anti-semitism uh seen by many as a gold
standard a a way that institutions can
adopt a definition that best protects
Jews in part because of how Ira provides
specific examples of when anti-zionism
constitutes
anti-Semitism on the right is the adl's
definition right the ADL one of the
leading organizations concerned with
Jewish safety and
insecurity happy to go over some of the
differences that we see in these
definitions in the Q&A but I wanted to
make sure that we were provided a
definition of
anti-semitism every presentation that I
give on anti-semitism I include this
quote from historian po because I think
it's critical that when we evaluate
anti-Semitism we understand that no
perpetrator ideology owns anti-Semitism
as we see anti-Semitism being weaponized
on the left and the right it's important
to remember that anti-Semitism manifests
in a multitude of ways Jews are always
showing off they are hermetic and
secretive they will not assimilate they
assimilate only too well they are too
religious they are too materialistic and
to threat to religion they are
uncultured they have too much culture
they avoid manual work they work too
hard they are miserly they are
ostentatious venders they're inveterate
capitalists they're born Communists and
so on in all its Myriad manifestations
the language of anti-Semitism Through
the Ages is addiction AR of nonsecretors
and antonyms at the source of the logic
and
inconsistency what are these enduring
questions that I mentioned things that
we struggle with that we don't yet have
generalizable answers to but are
absolutely critical in how we seek
measuring and tracking
anti-Semitism first and foremost who is
a
Jew is Jew is being Jewish something
that's scalable or is it
binary understanding this is absolutely
critical and there is again no
generalizable agreement on what
constitutes this m survey research a lot
of the work that I'm going to share with
you
today that explores specifically Jewish
perceptions much of this comes from the
idea of self-reporting one's Jewish
identity what is anti-Semitism how do we
Define anti-Semitism should we even use
the term anti-Semitism AJC did some
recent polling on this that said an
enormous proportion of
Americans near the majority of Americans
don't know how to define
anti-Semitism I haven't really heard of
it so perhaps we should push towards
using alternative terms that most
Americans would be able to identify as
representing Jew ha there's a movement
suggest that we should instead abusing
an semitism use the term
judic of course I mentioned the IRA
definition we said we saw a lot of
concern regarding this when Biden rolled
out his new plan to combat anti-Semitism
what definition should we use because if
we're not all utilizing the same
definition we're not all calling the
same balls and
Strikes should we be using BDA we have
Nexus we have several other definitions
of anti-Semitism that we should consider
and then of course anti-israel
anti-zionist beliefs when does holding
specific anti-israel sentiment or when
this manifestation of specific
anti-zionist beliefs actually constitute
anti-Semitism if
ever no generalizable agreement here
other things that I think we should
consider our measurement
concerns we do a lot of research most of
the tracking that we see most of what
Americans are exposed two are either
alleys of hate
crimes or some of the survey results
that I already
shared attitudes and behavior while we
like to think that these are connected
and linked in reality their relationship
is far less clear so we need to be
exploring research that really connects
specific attitudes to particular
manifestations that were most
concerned what about anti-semitism M and
philosemitism philosemitism being those
that
love these two phenomena are not only
linked sometimes when you measure them
they show up in the exact same ways some
people have gone as far to say that
philosemitism in and of itself is a form
of
anti-Semitism so it's critical as we're
trying to
decipher what constitutes anti-Semitism
are we measuring anti-semitism are we
measuring philosemitism are these terms
the same and especially in the United
States what many have called the most
philosemitic country in the world this
is an important thing that we have yet
to truly figure out in the discipline
and then of course latent
anism when we think about racism even
those that are the most vient racists
and bigots they don't always wear that
on their sleep it doesn't Define their
every action and
opportunity
often it takes a certain stimulus to
induce an
element of racism
indicatory much of anti-Semitism is lat
so how do we measure a phenomenon that
isn't necessarily empirically available
for
us I also want to talk a little bit
about General measures of anti-em when
it comes to our choices in doing
quantitative research we can look at
events the this often constitutes acts
of Terror hate crime variation bias
incident variation we can look at social
media Ms on
tweets YouTube Facebook Tik toks not
just the content itself not just content
frequency but the responsiveness of
these very Platforms in removing the
content how quickly they remove it are
they removing it for certain actors only
does it take a specific actor to report
the contct in order to remove it and
this has become very important of course
with Elon musk's takeover of the ad of
of excuse
me of of X Twitter x uh and and his
concern regarding the ADL and that P
policy we can look at governmental
discrimination here in the United States
we'd like to think that there is no
longer governmental discrimination
targeting Jews but across Europe and in
many other places Jews are not always
able to practice their religion freely
societal discrimination and
institutional discrimination are other
outlets that we can use to measure
antiem there's interesting work that's
now being done through Network analyss
looking at organizational connections
looking at group mapping looking at
extremist networks how are hate groups
organized how are they building content
how are they building followers and then
of course attitudes and beliefs what we
commonly evaluate through surveys but
also through interviews focus groups and
experiments we are having few technical
issues okay common descriptive
approaches right what we most frequently
see
surveys one of the biggest challenges we
have here is that anti-Semitism as I
mentioned is is an extremely challenging
phenomena to measure in 2022 the ADL
changed its battery that hadn't changed
since
1964 we added three
questions and we changed some of the
balances what do we see at the very top
when asking a naturally representative
sample 70% of Americans say that Jews
stick together more than other Americans
report that that's at least mostly are
somewhat true at the bottom
16% mostly say mostly or somewhat say
the Jews are not as honest as other
business
people anti-Semitism is multiactor there
are many ways in which it can manifest
so any survey that attempts to measure
it has these challenges how do we
measure all of these elements of
anti-Semitism we can look at incident
reporting and the ADL audit report is
something that's very common the FBI's
hate crime report that comes out
annually is another way that we can
evaluate anti-semitic incident variation
and anti-Semitism in the United States a
tremendous amount of money is going to
fund interventions and to generate
policy that combats anti-Semitism
through these primarily descriptive
approaches what I contend is that we
need to go further we need to do more
rigorous quantitative analysis we need
to understand
mechanisms that explain why certain
attitudes are more likely to lead to
anti-semitic Behavior through the
experimental work that I and others are
pursuing I'm hoping that that's going to
be the case so why experiments
experiments offer us a really unique way
to isolate specific factors and corals
we think explain variation in
anti-Semitism it helps us to evaluate
what are the structures of
anti-semitism in some cases as I
mentioned with latent anti-Semitism what
are the conditions that elevate
anti-Semitism what's the relationship
between attitudes and policy preferences
something I'm going to share today with
our research that explores hate crime
exposure and how does an exposure to a
specific narrative or event alter belief
in a traditional marketing sense message
test it's important to knowe right as I
OTE an experimental approach to
understanding anti-Semitism there are
shortcomings that we are constantly
considering the pster effect were what
many have known as interviewer effect
the emergence of specific
characteristics of the messenger or the
deliverer of a certain question altering
the way in which a respondent approaches
it one of the ways that you can do that
is to make sure that you have multiple
different characteristics of any sort of
enumerator any person that's responsible
for delivering it and to evaluate
whether or not there is this messenger
effect in place a bogus pipeline a way
to avoid some of the social desirability
concerns of a potential
respondent let them know that in fact we
are able to detect when they are L and
then of course pure control and vignette
control this is something my colleague
Jacob Scott Lewis and I are very
interested in is whether or not we
should be looking simply at a pure
control those that aren't exposed to any
sort of treatment or whether we should
also provide an innocuous treatment and
whether or our seemingly innocuous
treatment and whether or not that
actually creates different
findings so I'm going to go over briefly
now some of the most important pieces of
experimental literature in evaluating
anti-Semitism this is largely focused on
the work of mikal davich at University
of Warsaw who is the leading expert when
it comes to anti-Semitism
experimentation so one of the main
beliefs is that it's important for us as
Scholars to create typologies of
anti-Semitism what are the factors that
explain
anti-Semitism uh belich at all in 2013
Focus on authoritarian personality
characteristics they focus on victimhood
based social identity they f on relative
deprivation and they examined whether or
not this manifests in uh in these Factor
loadings here of focusing on a three
Factor structure of anti-Semitism
conspiratorial anti-Semitism traditional
religious and anti-judaic beliefs and
secondary anti-semitic beliefs those
that focus on Holocaust commemoration
they look at a population in Poland to
do this work what they're able to find
is that specific factors of
anti-Semitism help to explain variation
in how somebody would
choose to donate
resources to commemorate certain
elements of History specifically that
anti-semitic beliefs and holding of
anti-Semitic beliefs the possession of
it and the strength of those beliefs
help to make one choose to to to provide
those resources to a museum that's not
associated with the Holocaust but
instead a broader National Museum so
what this shows here what the summary
shows is that those that
hold traditional anti-semitic beliefs
secondary anti-semitic beliefs and
belief in Jewish conspiracy all donate
less money to Jewish
organizations a lot of concern is
focused on the contact hypothesis for
those that are not familiar with the
contact hypothesis originating with
alport in
1954 what uh stefanic at all due in 2022
is a meta analysis of eight different
studies evaluating active engagement
with historical ethnic diversity in
Poland the idea here was to provide a
specific curriculum for students across
polish high
schools and to evaluate whether or not
engaging in this curriculum with
Jews helps to reduce
anti-Semitism
participation in the intervention
contributes to building knowledge and
interest in local history more positive
attitudes towards Jewish people and
toward ethnic diversity in general
attendees of this
program developed strong stronger Place
attachment and Civic engagement in t
intentions but their General Social
trust and attitudes toward other ethnic
groups the Roma people remained largely
unchanged so this element this program
this curriculum works in the reduction
of anti-Semitism but it is not nearly as
effective in reducing broader forms
Prejudice a lot of individuals are
concerned with the notion of power and
anti-Semitism but also powerlessness
and
anti-Semitism what happens when people
lose their
agency what happens when there's a lack
of power a lack of control and feelings
of uncertainty so first and foremost we
know that lack of control and
uncertainty in the political domain are
highly
interconnected political
uncontrollability rather than political
uncertainty predicts individ idual
beliefs in Jewish conspiracies so what
happened in this case with this research
design one group was given a vignette
that focuses on political
uncontrollability the other was given a
a vignette that looks at political
uncertainty and what they find is that
it's the uncontrollability not
uncertainty it's the lack of agency that
helps to explain individual's beliefs in
Jewish conspiracy
political uncontrollability they find
predicts belief in Jewish conspiracy
even after controlling for anti-semitic
discriminatory ACS even when you control
for prior
beliefs the same study also shows that
lack of control may be specific
particularly to conspiracy stereotypes
of Jews and less specific to groups not
viewed as prototypical conspiring agents
it's specific to Jews not Germans not
Russians there's a direct relationship
between feelings of lack of control and
general conspiracies but that belief is
weak and there's an increase in the
endorsement of conspiracy are types of
Jews driving other conspiracy
beliefs great work from anel at all in
2015 and 2020 focusing on the Greek
context
they're really interested in
understanding this notion of competing
and Collective victim anti-Semitism
stems from a sense of collective
victimhood defined as a perception that
an individual's nation has been the
victim of history that is rooted in the
historical narratives found in education
and other socialization agents so what
do they do right they provide specific
vignettes that are aimed at increasing a
sense of comparative victim or
collectivity what they find is that
inducing ingroup favoritism leads
ingroup members to downplay the
collective suffering of
others this manifest through antagonism
with other groups widely acclaimed as
victims over the moral benefits emerging
from victimhood
status so to put it simply there's a
competition over victim that they're
identifying through this
process
now I think this is an experiment that
really is is useful for understanding a
lot of what's manifesting in America
today as it relates to hate speech and
as it relates to anti-semitic social
media
content the Sor at all piece shows that
lower sensitivity to hate crime uh
excuse me hate speech was a positive
mediator of the relationship between
frequent exposure to hate speech and
outward
Prejudice they provided desensitization
tra and what they found is that after
you desensitize somebody to hate
speech individuals were less sensitive
to hate speech and more Prejudice
towards uh hate speech victims than
their counterparts that were in the
control condition those that did not
receive that desensitization J the
effects of exposure to hate speech on
Prejudice were mediated by a lower
sensitivity to hate speech and not by a
lower sensitivity to social
norms and the last last piece that I
want to show you before going into my
own work is the mortality sence piece
and the double standards piece that was
done by Flor Cohen at all in
2009 the effect of mortality Sans and
when we say mortality sence the idea of
bringing up the idea of death the effect
of mortality sence on increasing support
for punishing countries that commit
human rights violations was most
strongly apparent in the Israel
condition so when you expose somebody
this idea of death it manifests with
specific anti-israel sentiments
and an increase in
anti-Semitism because anti-Semitism may
increase hostility to Israel it's hard
to parse things out and this is some of
what I'm trying to do now with my
experimental work so my work has long
focused on what we call the Homeland
diaspora Nexus understanding the role of
Jewish attachment and identity as it
relates to Israel but also how Israeli
behavior and perceptions of Israeli
Behavior affect the identity and
insecurity of Jews this is really a
combination of what I'd say are several
disciplines international relations
anti-Semitism and those that focus on
hate crimes a lot in
criminology and a lot in
sociology the main research question
that I'm interested in answering is what
is Israel's role in explaining variation
in anti-semitic events and hate
crimes I did a piece in
2019 that really explored this in the
European context right we've seen a lot
as it relates to some descriptive
statistics about spikes in anti-Semitism
when Israel is engaged in a violent
conflict in the Middle East operation
protective Edge looking at France and UK
here we see a massive in the month
that Israel's engaged in that operation
only to decline back to normal levels
just a month or two
later when I looked at data from 2009 to
2017 evaluating any month where Israel
uh casualties from War uh exceeded
100 we see a 35% rise in anti-semitic ha
crimes that are reported across 28
European
States I also looked at this in the
American
context the most philosemitic country in
the
world what did we find we found that
Israeli military operations the weeks in
which Israeli military operations took
place was the most important substantive
factor in explaining anti-semetic
incident variation here in the United
States total incidents increased by
roughly 24% in those weeks but what's
critical here is that violent incidents
increased by
33% right there there's a connection
between Israeli
violence and anti-semitic violence here
in the United
States and then on a college campus I I
think it's important to show this
research because a lot of concern about
anti-anisakis
Jews when compared to other minority
groups on college campuses are more
likely to experience hate
crimes and when you look at some of the
events or characteristics of a campus
that might explain anti-semitic incident
variation we see that the celebration of
Israel apartheid week the commemoration
of Israel aparti week and the active and
the presence of an active SJP chapter
both tied of course to the Israeli
Palestinian conflict helped to predict
increased anti
so I want to go into my own work now on
blame attribution and the responsibility
to speak out the idea here is that when
we see Jews being targeted for the
actions of Israel is it because
perpetrators blame Jews is there a
feeling that Jews the diaspora have a
responsibility to speak out against the
actions of Israel what is the mechanism
that explains the the decision to engage
in this Behavior so our research
question our diaspora communities or
those groups that are linked with
International actors blamed for the
actions of their home or an Associated
International act our Dias for
communities or groups linked with intern
International actors are they beli to
have a responsibility to speak out
against their homand and is this a case
of these phenomena only focus focus
using on Jews are diaspora Jews uniquely
blamed for the actions of their Homeland
and the only group responsible to speak
out against it how did we do this we
designed a survey what we did is we
utilized these experimental
vignettes what we did is we used an
image of a an apartment building and a
hospital that was damaged in AB bombin
but we changed who the target and the
perpetrator was on the first image you
see is or in the first story you see
Israel bombing Gaza on the second you
see Russia bombing Mar opal on the third
you see Saudi Arabia bombing son in the
EM we also have another image of Isis
operating in
Afghanistan we asked our survey
respondents on a scale of 1 to 10 how
much are the diaspora or the linked
group to blame for actions and policies
towards the target group so how might
this manifest in a series of questions
right we didn't just ask about Israel's
actions towards the Palestinians but in
those series how much are American Jews
to blame for Israel's actions and
policies towards the Palestinians
provide us somean on a scale of 1 to 10
same question but designed to also
capture responsibility to speak out what
do we find well when we look at
attribution of
blame only
Jews only Jews only those that were
exposed to the Israel treatment see an
increase in blame as a treatment
effect not American Russians that were
treated with the uh Russian treatment
not the Saudi Arabia and Isis treatments
that we provided this does not increase
American Muslims being blamed just
Jews this is a breakdown by ideology I
think this is critical to show in part
because one of the subf findings that I
I'm happy to go into in the Q&A but what
we see is that those on the far right
actually see a reduction in blame
towards Jews and see a significant
increase in blame towards musim Muslims
when they're exposed to our Israel VY
our Israel
treatment we see similar phenomena when
it comes to the attribution of
responsibility to speak up again only
the only the Israel treatment results in
a significant increase in the idea that
Jews have a responsibility to speak
out against that linked International
act in this case
Israel this is again a breakdown of
responsibility uh to speak out by
ideology I think it's useful on the left
we're looking at it broken down by Jews
Muslims and
Russians on the right we're looking at
it broken down by
ideology so to give you a brief finding
summary here blame of diasporas for
Associated conflicts is relatively low
across the board while applied
responsibilities substantively
higher we were surprised by this blame
and responsibility they don't seem to
operate on the same
scales only Jews those exposed to our
Israel
treatment see a significant increase in
both blame and
responsibility those on the right
broadly speaking blame Muslims more than
any other ideology blames any other
diaspora or linked group those on the
left believe Jews are blameworthy and
responsible to speak out more than
Muslims or
Russians in building on recent
scholarship examining anti-Semitism on
the extremes what we're really finding
here is that the effects of the
treatment are manifesting in the
greatest substantive Fashion on the
ideological extremes this treatment
effect is magnifying on our political
polls when and I want to introduce you
to just one other uh experiment hate
crime exposure and foreign policy
preferences we know that hate crime
reporting has gone up there's greater
media exposure to hate
crimes this is an image of a CNN report
uh examining anti-semitic hate crimes in
the United
States we
know how hate crimes affect the target
population
but what does it do how does it alter
policy preferences at a national
level we ask how does exposure to
anti-semitic hate crimes alter foreign
policy preferences not amongst Jews but
looking at a nationally representative s
specifically does exposure to
anti-semitic ha crime alter foreign
policy preferences towards
Israel and even more
specifically does it manifest in certain
elements of foreign policy is this
something that's going to be specific to
a general Alliance something that we
associate perhaps military
aid or preferential
trait we provided a series of vignettes
to our respondents one that focuses on a
vandalism attack one that focuses on a
physical
attack we also vary
what the motivation
was in some cases the perpetrator is
graffitiing death to Jews in some cases
it's death to Israel same with the
statement in the physical attack death
to Jews or death to
Israel we also change the identity of
the perpetrator all factors that we
think might help to explain variation in
foreign policy
preferences
so how do we ask this how do we begin to
assess foreign policy we ask in your
opinion how important is it for the
United States to maintain a strong
alliance with Israel but we also ask
that same question of a battery of other
countries we ask them to indicate their
level of support for US military
assistance we ask them to indicate their
level of support for preferential trade
with Israel and again a series of other
countries what do we find
we find that those that are exposed to
hate
crime across the
board find it more
important to provide military assistance
to Israel they find it more important to
have a general alliance with Israel they
find it more important to provide
preferential trade agreements for
Israel and we're wondering why why is
this taking place what are we
seeing is this manifesting because of
the sense of personal
threat so we're exposing people to this
treatment we're exposing them to a story
of a hate crime does it make them feel
personally threatened to do that we
don't find considerable evidence that's
actually the case well does this also
manifest perhaps an increased feeling of
incre St towards racial communities this
this inducing that phenomenon don't find
considerable evidence of that either but
what we see is that exposing our
respondents to hate crime anti-semitic
hate crime does incre increase a general
sense of threat
towards all religious communities with
the exception of the dominant religious
community in this country the Protestant
community
so those that are exposed to the hate
crimes when compared to our control
group right feel
considerably uh feel that there's
considerable threat towards religious
communities in the United
States so to just go over briefly
finding summary here exposure to
anti-semitic attacks caused strong
support for pro-israel policies relative
to the control group out group exposure
to hate crime increase perceived support
for the victim group at least via
preferences that we measured V
Associated foreign policies in their
weight and what's so critical here is a
baked in normative
consequence it suggests that those that
are committing acts of
hate are actually generating policy
preferences and potential support for
policies that presumably they
oppose
doing a lot of really interesting future
survey work again trying to utilize this
as a a an approach to examine
anti-Semitism and the mechanisms of
anti-Semitism in in critical ways
focusing on elements of
conspiracy
whiteness hope and cooperation
comparative Prejudice so not just
focusing on anti-Semitism specifically
utilizing specific message
testing and also focusing on the
effective of
interventions and I want to close with
this work that was recently done in our
ADL uh our 2022 ADL
survey we asked
respondents do you think this individual
pictured
here who may be from the Jewish singer
from Israel the singer that performs in
the United States we an Arab singer from
Iraq so again to clarify here some
people were given this
treatment another series of people were
given this treatment in the last series
were given this treatment do you
consider this person to be
white what we found was that those who
were told that the individual picture
was Jew was a Jewish singer from Israel
were significantly more likely to
identify the individual's
life those that were given the singer
from the USA or an Arab singer from
Iraq no significant difference between
the two white respondents who viewed the
Jewish Israeli singer as white endorsed
fewer tropes fewer anti-semitic tropes
than right respondents who viewed him as
non-white and among non-white
respondents the perceived whiteness
really didn't have a measurable impact
on
anti-Semitism this individual is due to
he is an Iraqi Jewish singer living in
Israel so I'm going to close there just
always close with images of my cats and
my daughter any questions or concerns
comments again a lot of this is in the
early stages so we really welcome your
support and your work and your feedback
please feel free to email me at my grats
email uh thank you very much for your
time really
appreciate thank you um a for that um
very interesting presentation and I know
um some people have uh written in that
there's an echo problem hopefully that's
been taken care of we apologize we're
still trying to figure out this
technology yeah I apologize everybody
for my my clicker happiness throughout
I'm sorry um okay so a bunch of
questions from the audience I have some
questions too one quick question that
just came up um is could you explain the
hyphen I mean this is uh you know in
anti-Semitism this is something that
that you know always comes up in
anti-Semitism studies so are are you a
hyphen or no and what does that mean so
from the very beginning I uh would write
to editors that I'm okay with the
decision of uh the the journal to to
choose how
anti-Semitism uh should should be
spelled I was never somebody that focus
on this because I felt that it took away
from more of the meaningful impactful
research that we could be doing
examining the manifestations of
anti-Semitism I believe there is a place
for definitional concerns of
anti-Semitism um and I applaud the
scholars that engage in it but it's not
the area of focus for me the the origin
of this is um commonly expressed as
related to this not of there being
noetic people that being semetic is
actually a language orientation and
therefore by making getting rid of the
hypen and making it
anti-Semitism right we're making this a
phenomena that's specific to Jews but
I'll go back to the comment um from from
the slide where I talked about this very
subject which is that many people in the
United States a huge proportion of
people in the United States don't know
what anti-Semitism is so this is uh part
of a broader debate that we need to be
having in terms of clarifying the
visibility of the
subject okay great um so a question
about um AI um yeah so can you talk a
little bit about AI generated
anti-Semitism is this posing an even
greater risk than what you know we were
experiencing before U and maybe just
tell for audience members who aren't you
know familiar with um AI what we're
talking about here so first of all I am
no expert in AI myself so let me make
that clear there there are some
individuals that are working on this
research um that that that know it much
better than I do but the idea here is
that in fact you can take the coret of
of anti-Semitic propaganda that work the
best in terms of
influence in terms of
Recruitment and
generate truly excellent
anti-semitic
propaganda um it can help you generative
AI can help you in terms of finding the
best Avenue in which to advertise this
or present this material it can help you
in recruiting it recruiting uh specific
individuals by testing this back and
forth uh you can provide generative AI a
variety of different uh elements of
propaganda and it can refine it for you
um I can tell you that this is something
that's deep concern in the intelligence
Community um and it's worthy worthy of
of studying and evaluating further I can
tell you that definitely there are
actors that are utilizing AI uh for the
purpose of making anti-semitic uh
propaganda and rhetoric
um more
impactful um thank you so a question a
few questions actually about um your
surveys and um
are there um generational differences in
how people respond to the survey how do
you control for that well we always
control for age for Education anything
related to SCS we control for religion
we control for any of the demographic
factors the geographic factors that are
are critical in designing a naturally
representative sample um there are some
interesting generational effects um we
see that there is not always uh uh this
uh linear effect as it relates to age
many people assume that anti-Semitism is
going to be
highest among the oldest population that
is not always the case depends on the
specific element of anti-Semitism you're
trying to measure uh for example when it
comes to anti-zionism right anti Zionism
um and again not that all anti Zionism
is anti-Semitism but anti-zionist
anti-Semitism right is actually lowest
amongst the uh the the oldest
generations and it's highest amongst the
younger I think that comes as no
surprise to many people but uh elements
of anti-Semitism that are related to
power related to economics right that's
often times a a millennial phenomenon
right in part because of the exogenous
factors that they experienced as it
relates to the
recession okay and so would you say that
there are different anti ANS semitisms
in like we're talking about the American
context right now so for instance we
have what's going on you know arguably
on college campuses but that seems to me
anyway very different from um Orthodox
Jews on the streets in Brooklyn getting
attacked so how does your how do your
surveys get at those different kinds of
anti-Semitism because it strikes me that
you know it's it's picking up something
but it's maybe not picking up those
differences so yeah I I think that there
are different elements of why Jews might
be targeted for specific behavior first
of all when we think about the broadest
structure possible you have to be able
to identify a perpetrator right if
you're able to identify a perpetrator or
excuse me identify a Target perpetrator
needs to identify a Target when you
identify a specific Target right when we
think about Jews right not all Jews are
going to be identifiable to a
perpetrator there's not and even just
distribution of Jewish institutions that
can be part of it so specific areas
where there's a higher concentration of
use including American college campuses
uh are going to see let's say an
increased likelihood of anti-Semitic
hate crime as a consequence that's going
to be different right than areas that
have fewer Jews um when it comes to
thinking about this topic in in uh from
from a visibly Jewish standpoint
thinking about let's say um Orthodox or
ready communities um yes we knowe that
there's higher uh likelihood of hate
crimes that are targeting those
individuals when asking th those
individuals about their experience
they're more likely to say that they
experience uh anti-semitic rhetoric
being the victims of of an anti-semitic
incident so again this all plays a role
in the likelihood of a and do you see
that there's more um measurable
anti-semitism on college campuses with
greater Jewish populations so we find
that yes the larger the Jewish
population the greater the number of
incidents that are being reported uh we
find that the proportion of Jews so when
we think about it from a percentage
standpoint that's not a great predictor
of explaining anti-semitic incidents on
campus so you need a certain critical
mass Jews to to to experience
considerable antism but you do find that
in on College campuses and and that's
true kind of across the board like it
really correlates that that um or is it
how do how how have you guys you know
who's studying that and and what have
they there there's lots of research
that's really trying to examine this
issue uh the work that I did was a
project for for a what I did is I looked
at uh Hill International's report on
Jewish populations across different
institutions we looked at the Oma
incident rates that have been reported
um and we evaluated whether or not there
was a relationship between the size of
the Jewish population of that
institution as long as as well as
Prestige as well as Geographic
characteristics uh acceptance rates we
we we looked at a variety of different
coats but we found that one of the most
important predictive factors of whether
or not an institution would see
heightened anti-semitism was for the
size population okay here's a question
that um I'm not sure you'll be able to
answer but I'd love to just hear what
you think which is if Israel weren't in
the picture would the incidence of
anti-Semitism still be on the rise is it
impossible
this I love and hate
counterfactuals um if Israel wasn't here
would incident still be on the rise I
what I'd say is that it's really
important that we don't think about
anti- Zionism and anti-israel sentiment
is something that exists exclusively
with one ideological domain one of the
things that I often do I didn't do it in
this presentation is I show two
vehemently anti-zionist quotes um one
coming from leis farakhan and the other
coming from Matthew kbach who is a
relatively Infamous Neo-Nazi here in the
United States again the idea here is
that
anti-Semitism right didn't exist I I
mean do doesn't oh anti- excuse me
anti-semitism
doesn't exist exclusively in specific
ideological domains it doesn't um I
think anti-zionism specifically and
anti-zionism
anti-Semitism is a convenient way to
um to manifest certain elements of
anti-Semitism in a more socially
acceptable way um it's not always that
case but I think it's a useful tool for
that reason
um if Israel wasn't here would we see it
on their rise I don't know obviously and
I would refute anybody who says that
they do but anti semitism has existed
from Millennia um so I I imagine it
would still be here and the most
infamous incidents of anti-Semitism in
this country existed prior to the
creation of
Israel and um so a lot of your studies
are the ones you showed um today
reflected we're trying to control or
trying to examine incident you know
anti-semitic feelings according to
political um you know positions but what
about are you studying or is anybody
studying the effect of um like family
background or levels of stress and
anxiety in the home or um things like
that and how that contributes to um
anti-semitic um so more kind of
psychological profiles of the
perpetrators of perpetrators yeah yeah
that's a really interesting question I
think it's hard to get access to that
data right uh first thing when we think
about hate crimes and reported hate
crimes we look at reports that are
coming from policing
agencies the number of hate crime
prosecutions in this country is
remarkably low so those that we can
really definitively say are perpetrators
of a hate crime using that definition of
being convicted of a hate crime profiles
on that sense uh are really mostly
available in the comparative sense
in a qualitative sense less so a
quantitative sense um Are there specific
elements uh of someone's upbringing that
makes them more likely to potentially
engage in anti-semitic behavior um we
can look to some of the work from
perpetrators themselves reporting on
this issue um sense of loneliness a
needing to belong uh in a non-nuclear
family structure uh these are things
that explain uh hate crime perpetration
potentially but they also explain all
crime perpetration so it's really hard
to to disentangle yeah and I've heard
gther jelli um you know some of his
research which has shown that maybe you
know
counterintuitively um you know levels of
poverty didn't really see in in studying
um anti-Semitism in European um Muslim
communities um it wasn't correlated
necessarily with so socioeconomic
background but much more with exposure
to you know extreme religious ideologies
um so okay we're basically out of time
but I wanted to end on maybe a more
hopeful note by what about what research
is being done on which Solutions work
best for um you know uh solving
anti-Semitism or making it at least a
little bit better I think there's a
really big push now to try try to figure
out anti-Semitism interventions uh ways
in which we can reduce both the causes
of anti-Semitism how we can generate
policy that prevents the manifestations
of anti-Semitism the behavior and then
also right how do we assess right the
effectiveness of these elements of these
policies of these interventions um a lot
of this is being done through education
um there's actually really amazing work
that's being done by josal and David
that I will let them speak to because I
don't believe it's yet out uh but
they're doing fantastic work evaluating
the various ways in which one can
intervene to reduce anti-Semitism from
both an educational and a policy
perspective um there's a question of
whether contact is going to be effective
if it's a specific type of contact UM
again I showed you the some of the work
uh on that from the Polish context uh I
can tell you that from working with some
some Scholars in Norway uh Pathfinders
program specifically what they've done
is expose individuals to Norwegian Jews
communities that normally don't have
Norwegian Jews focusing on the Norwegian
elements of that Jewish individual's
experience and they see a considerable
reduction in anti-Semitism but also
Prejudice towards other minority groups
and marginalized groups in Norway so
there are avenues that are being
explored but it's widely understood
amongst those Scholars studying an
semitism that this is the area that's
received the least Rous attention Okay
terrific well thank you so much for your
really enlightening talk and thank you
to um everyone in the audience for your
questions I urge everybody if you're not
already to please get on the yipa ypsa
mailing list we have a lot of um
interesting uh programming this year and
look forward to seeing you all at future
events so please join me in thanking a
fineberg